لا تكاد تهدا زوبعه حتى تثور اخرى اعنف
واشد وقعا يحدث ذلك في فرنسا بارتباط مع
احداث داميه كان اخرها مقتل مدرس فرنسي
عرض على طلابه في ضواحي باريس صوره مسيئ
للرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم تقول الشهادات
ان ذلك كان في معرض حديث المدرس الفرنسي
عن حريه التعبير والمعتقد لكن بعدها
بساعات لفض انفاسه الاخيره على يدي شاب من
اصول شيشانيه يقيم في البلاد من بين ردود
الفعل على العمليه اعلان الرئيس الفرنسي
امانويل ماكرون ان القتيل ضحيه لما سماه
الارهاب
الاسلامويين جديد حول الاشاره الى ديانه
المهاجمين عندما يتعلق الامر
بمسلمين باريس حزينه فثم من قتل بل قطع
راسه على يد شاب صغير السن من اصول
شيشانيه حدث هذا حسب الروايات الرسميه لان
القتيل وهو مدرس تاريخ عرض لطلابه رسوما
كاريكاتوريه مسيئه الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم خلال درس عن حريه التعبير
والمعتقد الى المدرسه التي كان القتيل
يعمل فيها هرع الرئيس امانويل ماكرون
قائلا ان المدرس تعرض لهجوم ارهابي اسلامو
وهو ما كرره رئيس وزرائه جان كاستكس بينما
قال المدعي العام في اداره مكافحه الارهاب
ان جماعه تدعى انصار شيشان اعلنت
مسؤوليتها عن الجريمه وان اختا للمنفذ
كانت عضوا في تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
اهو هجوم على مبادئ الجمهوريه كما اجمع
على ذلك الساس الفرنسيون ذاك ما سبق
لماكرون ان كرره قبل نحو اسبوعين حين زار
حيا في الضواحي داعيا لتصدي لما سماها
الانعزاليه الاسلاميه وقال ان هناك من
يسعى الى اقامه نظام مواز في البلاد ثم
خلص الى ان الاسلام ديانه تعيش الان ازمه
في كل مكان من العالم وقد اثارت تلك
التصريحات غضبا واسعا ووصفها الرئيس
التركي بالوقاحه واعتبرها دليلا على عدم
احترام الاديان الاخرى وياتي مقتل المدرس
الفرنسي بعد نحو شهر ونصف من اعاده شارلي
ابدو نشر الرسوم الموسئ وفعلت ذلك
بالتزامن مع محاكمه شركاء محتملين لمنفذ
الاعتداءات على الصحيفه في يناير من عام
2015 اعاده نشر تلك الرسوم الموسئ اثارتي
الاخرى غضبا كبيرا في عدد من الدول
الاسلاميه وخلقت اجواء مشحونه قد تكون
وراء را مهاجمه شاب باكستاني شخصا باله
حاده بالقرب من مقر الصحيفه القديم ويرى
بعض ان ثمت
تضخيماً خطابه الشعبوي من قبل بعض الساسه
لاستثماره انتخابيا من العوامل التي ادت
الى اعاده انتاج متعسف للعدو ممثلا في
الاسلام دون غيره ويلفت هؤلاء النظر الى
ان ابشع الجرائم ضد المسلمين في الغرب
حدثت في مارس من العام الماضي في
نيوزيلندا انذاك اقتحم مسلح مسجدين وقتل
عشرات المصلين ولكن من دون ان يقال ان
دوافعه ذات صله بديانته فهل ثمت معايير
مزدوجه بهذا الخصوص يتساءل اصحاب هذا
الراي ويقولون ان جاسيندا اردرن رئيسه
وزراء نيوزيلندا ادارت تداعيات هجومي
كرايست شيرش بتفهم وترفع كبيرين وهو ما
لاقى ترحيبا في العالم الاسلامي بينما
هناك من يسارع الاتهام الاسلام وشيطنته
حتى لو جاء الحديث عن الارهاب
الاسلامويين وصورتهم ضحيتها الحقيقيه قبل
غيرهم مناقشه هذا الملف ينضم الينا من
الدوحه دكتور
محمد مختار شقيتي استاذ الاخلاق السياسيه
وتاريخ الاديان في جامعه حمد بن خليفه
وسيلتحق بنا بعد قليل من باريس ايف بوزو
دي بورجو العضو السابق في مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي ابدا معك في هذا الوقت دكتور
الشنقيطي هل تعتقد بان ما يجري اليوم في
فرنسا هو صراع
يترجم
بالعنف من
الجانبين دون ان يجري ارساء حل فعلي لهذه
المشكله اعتقد اولا ان ما حدث في فرنسا
اليوم لا شك
انه جريمه بشعه او او امس وليس اليوم لا
شك انها جريمه بشعه هذا امر مفروغ منه لكن
للاسف هذه الجريمه جاءت في سياق جاءت في
سياق من التازم الاجتماعي والثقافي
والخطاب الشعبوي الذي
يستقطب ويحاول ان يحشر المسلمين في
الزاويه وهم الان حوالي 10% من سكان
فرنسا وهذا طبعا هذا النوع من الاجواء غير
الصحيه للاسف يغذي
احيانا الارهاب والعنف وغيره ثم مشكله
الخطاب وهو ما يسم ما يسما بالانجليزيه
انكرش باي اسوسيشن او التجريم بالاشتراك ف
اشتراك الناس في دين او في عرق او في
جنسيه ا اذا ارتكب مرتكب جريمه
على مستوى الفرد اذا ربطنا هذه الجريمه
باسم ذلك الدين او تلك الجنسيه او ذلك
العرق هذا هو التجرين بالاشتراك هو من
اسوا ما يكون من انواع انماط التحامل على
الشعوب وعلى الثقافات وعلى الحضارات وهذا
للاسف ما يحدث في الاعلام الفرنسي بدلا من
التعامل مع الجريمه باعتبارها الجريمه في
النهايه هو شاب قتل فرنسيا ثم قتلته
الشرطه وهنالك قضاء ودوله عريقه في مجال
المكله ان هناك تنظيم يقال ان اسمه انصار
الشيشان هو من تبنى سارع الى التبني وهذا
اعطى
البعد حتى ولو كان تنظيما هذا التنظيم
الذي لم يسمع به احد نفترض ان هذا التنظيم
موجود وان في عشرات او مئات الاعضاء من
اصل مليار ونصف مليار مسلم فهل هذا يناسب
ان نربط الموضوع باسم الاسلام اعتقد ان
هذا من الظلم وايضا اعتقد ان المسلمين
قبول المسلمين بان يحشروا بالزاويه بهذه
الطريقه هو نوع من من الضعف لدى المسلمين
فالحقيقه لابد من تجنب قضيه هذا النوع من
التجريم بالاشتراك ما ورد في التقرير انا
لم اسمع ابدا مسؤولا في اي دوله
اسلاميه يربط اسم المسيحيه بما حدث في
نيوزيلندا مثلا ورئيس الوزراء
النيوزيلنديه عالجت الموضوع بكل حكمه على
عكس تماما ماكرون في تعامله مع هذا النوع
من الموضوعات التي يحاول ان يفتعلها واذا
واذا وجدت بالفعل يحاول ان يستغل
استغلالا سياسيا
سيئ انضم الينا الان ايف بوزو دي بوركو
استدي بوركو لماذا التحامل على ديانه
عمرها اكثر من 1500 عام ولديها اكثر من
مليار ونصف المليار
معتنق بمجرد ان فردا واحدا قام بما قام
به
انا لست اوافق مع ما قاله البروفيسور ففي
فرنسا الامور تسير بخير بين المسلمين
واليهود
والمسيحيين كل شيء كان يحصل بطريقه جيده
ولكن منذ حوالي عر سنوات بدات تحصل
اعتداءات دائما كانت اعتداءات عنيفه جدا
ودميه جدا نتحدث عن الاعتداء في شارلي
ايبدو ومن ثم في باتاكلان
وكل مره كل الامور كانت تسير بخير بين
المسلمين
والاديان الاخرى في فرنسا ولكن الامور
بدات منذ سبع او ثمان سنوات واستمرت حاليا
نتحدث عن
267 اعتداء
1267 67
ضحيه هذه الضحايا او هذه الاعتداءات
بالاحرى
حصلت ليس لان المسلمين يتم استهدافهم هم
يشكلون جزءا من الحياه الفرنسيه المسلمون
هم جزء من حياتنا اليوميه ولا اعتقد فعلا
ان ما يقوله حضره البروفيسور صحيح اعتقد
ان هناك مشكله طبعا هناك بعض المسلمين
الذين يعتبرون هم متطرفون راديكالي
ويعتبرون انه يجب ان يقاتلوا ضمن الدول
الغربيه انا اقول ذلك لاننا جميعا في
فرنسا نرغب في ان نجمع مع فرنسا كلها بد
واحده مع المسلمين لكي نتمكن من الوقوف ضد
هذا الاسلام الراديكالي وانا اعارض تماما
ما قاله البروفيسور هو واضح انه لا يعرف
ما يحصل في فرنسا هذا غير صحيح ولدينا
الكثير من الاراده وما قاله اذا كبير ائمه
فرنسا ما قاله كان منطقيا وقال ان خاب ظنه
لان المرتكب من ديانته ولكننا جميعا في
فرنسا نريد ان
نقف ضد هذا الاسلام الراديكالي واعتقد ان
ما اقوله مهم جدا ولكنه ياتي على نقيد مما
قاله البروفيسور هو ربما لم يزر فرنسا يجب
ان يزور فرنسا وان يستعلم اكثر وان يرى
بام العين ان اراده السياسيين والمسلمين
واليهود وال المسيحيين كلهم يريدون ان
يتعايشوا الاسلام جزء من فرنسا والمسيحيه
واليهوديه ايضا ومنذ وما يحصل هو فقط ضمن
فئه من الاشخاص الارهابيين الذين يريدون
ان يقووا الاستقرار في البلاد طيب هذا كله
لا يعارضك احد عليه لولا انك تربط هذه
الاعتداءات بالدين بدين
الاسلام يعني قبل ايام قليله كان لديكم
جريمه ضد الشابه فيكتورين وهناك الكثير من
الجرائم التي تحدث ربما اكثر من 267
اعتداء الذين تحدثت عنهم وهناك جرائم
اغتصاب لماذا لا
يجري وسم هؤلاء المجرمين بديانتهم كما
يجري مع
مجرم لانه مسلم
فيصبح تصبح الجريمه ملتصقه بكل
الدين
سيدتي المشكله التي تقع نحن لسنا نحن
من نقوم بهذا الوسم هم الذين يقتلون باسم
الله ونعرف انهم ليسوا المسلمين نعرف ان
هناك فئه صغيره وشريحه صغيره من الاشخاص
الذين هم على هذا النحو ويقتلون باسم
ديانه ديانه المسلمين ونحن نعرف ان
المسلمين يقفون معنا هناك الكثير من
المسؤولين
والا المساجد الين يفكرون مثلنا وكن دائما
يبقى هناك شريحه هامشيه تقتل باسم الاسلام
طيب ولكن سيد سدي بورجو ماذن بال الاسلام
اذا كان هناك من يقتل باسمه ما ذنبه هو
كدين ما ذنب المليار الذي يتبعه وليس
بارهاب الديانه الاسلام ليس
مذنبا نحن لا نقول ان الاسلام هو مذنب
نتحدث عن بعض الاشخاص الذين يدعون انه من
الاسلام وانهم يقتلون باسمه ولكن احدا لا
يعتبر الاسلام مذنبا كما تقولين هناك اكثر
من مليار مسلم وهذا لا يعني انهم ارهابيون
هم يعيشون دياناتهم ويمارسون شعائرهم حتى
في فرنسا هنا لدينا ست ملايين مسلم وكل
شيء يجري بخير يعيشون معتقداتهم واسلامهم
كما فع الكاثوليك واليهود ولكن الامر
الوحيد هو ان هناك دائما هذه الاعتداءات
ال
267 مع اشخاص يقولون انه من الاسلام
ويدعونه نعرف انهم ليسوا مسلمين هم الذين
يدعون ذلك اعتقد انه من المهم جدا ان يكون
المسؤولون والقاضى في الدول المسلمه
والاسلاميه ان تدرك ان المسلمين في فرنسا
يعيشون بكل رفاه واحترام وان نتعايش معهم
في الحياه اليوميه ولكن يبقى ان هناك بعض
الاشخاص الارهابيين وهؤلاء الارهابيون هم
الذين يقتلون باسم الاسلام اذا دكتور
الشنقيطي يقول يقول لك سيد ايف بوزو ساعود
اليك سيد ايف بوزو ايف بوزو دي بورجو يقول
لك الاسلام ليس موصوفا بالارهاب هناك من
يستخدمه
و مرفوض وهم يعرفون بان هؤلاء الذين
يستخدمونه ليسوا اصلا
بمسلمين اولا انا اطمن الضيف الكريم اني
متابع للاعلام فرنسي بشكل دقيق و درست
اللغه الفرنسيه وانا الصبي وانتمي الى
دوله كانت مستعمره فرنسيه وتوجد ف الثقافه
الفرنسيه اضافه الى اني زرت فرنسا ايضا
فلا اتحدث من فراغ لكن اذكره بانه منذ سنه
من الان كانت هنالك جريمه بشعه في مسجد
ارتكبها شاب استرالي في نيوزيلندا وارتكب
باسم المسيحيه وترك وثيقه من 70 صفحه
يتحدث بها عن دوافعه الدينيه ومع ذلك لم
يوجد مسؤول في اي دوله مسلمه لا رئيس ولا
وزير ولا مسؤول يحترم نفسه ابدا سماه هذا
ارهابا مسيحيا ولا اسرائيل التي تحتل
الفلسطينيين وتعذبهم منذ 70 عاما لا لا
يتحدث المسؤولون العرب عن ارهاب يهودي
وانما يتكلمون عن الصهيونيه كحركه سياسيه
مثلا وغيره نحن نحن ندين هذه الجرائم التي
حدثت في في فرنسا يعني بالنسبه اليك لهذا
ولاذاك ارهابي دكتور يعني بالنسبه
اليك يعني هنا المشكله ايضا تبدو وكانه
كان في تعريف الارهاب ما هو الارهاب لانه
اذا كان الذي نفذ الجريمه في نيوزيلندا
ليس ارهابيا وهذا ليس ارهابيا من هو
الارهابي والاسرائيلي ليس ارهابي اذا هناك
مشكله في تعريف الارهاب اليس كذلك لا لا
انا لا اقصد الارهاب انا لا اقصد الارهاب
ما حدث في نيوزيلندا ارهاب وما يحدث في
اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين ارهاب لكن نحن لا
نسمي هذا لا نرق هذا لا بالديانه المسيحيه
ولا بالديانه اليهوديه وما حدث في فرنسا
ارهاب ايضا حتى الان يسمعك الضيف الاخر
اذا هذا النوع من الجرائم هو ارهاب
بالنسبه
اليك هذه هذا ارهاب وتسميته ارهاب تسميه
دقيقه سواء ما حدث في فرنسا امس او ما حدث
في نيوزيلندا منذ سنه او جميل سانقل هذا
اض الى
ايوو وصلت فكرتك دكتور يا سيد بجو لتوضيح
جمله واحده تفضل انا الذي اعترض عليه هو
هو النعت هو التوصيف الاسلام لماذا يسميه
اسلام لماذا لماذا يا سيد بجو لماذا
تقولون اسلامي اسم او اساويه وانت اعدت
تغريد مقال يتحدث او يحذر من تغلغل
الاسلام السياسي في الحياه الفرنسيه وايضا
اعترضت على ما قاله دارمان وزير الداخليه
عندما قال الاسلام لن يجد مشكله في
التعاون مع الجمهوريه الفرنسيه وكانك تشير
فعلا الى الاسلام لماذا سيد
بورجو
من الحياه الفرنسيه ببساطه وانتم محقون
فعلا حول ما حصل في نيوزيلندا نحن طبعا
ندين ما حصل في نيوزيلندا نحن ايضا ندين
ذلك نحن ندرك ان هذا ارهاب من اليمين
المتطرف ونحن ندين ذلك ونحن نقف معكم في
ذلك بالنسبه الى ما حصل في فرنسا هو انه
ليس الاسلام ما ارتكبه ولكنهم اشخاص
يقتلون ويقولون انهم يقتلون باسم الاسلام
وهذا خاطئ وتعرفون ذلك لان الاسلام ليس
كذلك انهم اشخاص
راديكالي طيب عندما يقول فيون في في عنوان
كتابه فانكرت اسلاميك
يعني يعني
مواجهه استخدم الانتصار على على على
التوتاليتاري الاسلام حتى وليس
الاسلاميه هنا كيف يعني كيف سيد بورجو
تريد من المسلمين ان يتقبلوا استخدام اسم
ديانتهم في رفضكم لمشروع سياسي ما ربما
مبرر ان تدين الارهاب او او مؤكد ان من
المفترض رفض الارهاب لكن ما دخل كلمه
الاسلام سواء اسلامي اسم او اسلاميك
اسلامي او اسلامو لماذا تقحمون كلمه اسلام
في تعبيركم عند ادانه جري مدان بالفعل لكن
لماذا اقحام كلمه اسلام هنا
المشكله اود ان
اقول اود ان اقول للبروفيسور اننا لا ندين
الاسلام الاسلام هو جزء من الحياه
الفرنسيه انا لا افهم ما يقصده حديثه
بالنسبه الينا الاسلام والمسلمون جزء من
الحياه الفرنسيه يتعايشون معنا في فرنسا
يعني اعطيك مثلا اقرب لك صوره ما يقصده
الدكتور شنقي عندما مثلا جرى الاعتداء
وقتل كل هؤلاء الضحايا في المسجد في
نيوزيلندا هل انت مع تسميه من قام بهذا
الاعتداء بانه بانه ارهاب مسيحي وبان
الارهابي ارهابي
مسيحي اذا لماذا لماذا تقولون ها
اس اننا ادنا هذا الاعتداء وادناه بعنف
حتى وحتى نزلنا وسرحنا بذلك لا اتحدث عن
هذا سيدي بورجو مره اخرى اعذرني مره
اخرى الخلاف هو ليس على يعني وصف الجريمه
بالارهاب هي ارهاب سواء في نيوزيلندا او
في فرنسا لنقول لكن المشكله هي في الحاق
صفه الدين بالفعل الارهابي يعني هل انت مع
ان
نسمي المجرم في نيوزيلندا بانه ارهابي
مسيحي يمكن ربما ان نقول ذلك لانه فعلا
كان شخصا من اليمين المتطرف نعم يمكن ان
نصفه بالارهابي المسيحي انا ليس لدي كل
المعلومات حول ما حصل في نيوزيلندا وقد
ادنا ذلك بعنف وبصرا وقلناها اكثر من مره
هذا عمل ارهابي في نيوزيلندا
ولكنني هنا ما لا افهم ما يقوله
البروفيسور
الشنقيطي يجب ان ندرك ان المسلمين يشكلون
جزء اساسيا من حياتنا والاسلام جزء من
حياتنا في فرنسا انا ازور المسجد في باريس
وانا ارتاح هناك انا احب زياره المسجد
وانا لا افهم المشكله لماذا لا نريد ان
نعترف بوجود ارهابيين قد ارتكبوا
267 حادثه ويقولون كل مره هم انفسهم انهم
يقتلون باسم الاسلام كما لو كان او كما
فعل الارهابي في نيوزيلندا ان وقال انه
يقتل باسم المسيحيه هذا لا يعني ان
المسيحيه هي التي قتلت الامر سيام بالنسبه
الينا ويجب ان ندرك ان الاسلام والمسلمين
موجودون معنا في فرنسا ويشاركون في حياتنا
اليوميه هل تفهم
وانا لا اوافق البروفيسور هنا اعتقد ان
هناك مشكله عدم فهم واضح نحن نعرف انه
ليسوا المسيحيين وليسوا المسلمين الذين
يقومون بهذه الاعتداءات ليست الديانه ولكن
هناك اشخاص في نيوزيلندا او في فرنسا
يدعون او يقولون انهم يقتلون باسم ديانتهم
نتحدث هنا عن 27 ضحيه في الاعتداءات التي
حصلت في فرنسا البروفيسور هو شخص حكيم
واستاذ في العلاقات السياسيه يجب ان يدرك
انه ليس الاسلام الملام هنا ولكن هؤلاء
الاشخاص يقتلون باسم الاسلام كما حصل في
نيوزيلندا ربما هذا الشخص الذي قال انه
فعل ذلك باسم المسيحيه لا اعرف واذا قال
ذلك هذا مودان يجب ان نقف ضد هذه
الاعتداءات وليس ضد الديانات الديانات جزء
من حياتنا في حياتكم وفي حياتنا نحن
دكتور دكتور الشنقيطي اذا هو لا يمانع حتى
في
وصف مجرم نيوزيلندا بانه ارهابي
مسيحي لا انا اعتقد هذا خطا فادح بكل اسف
هو ظلم
للمسيحيين المسيحيون يا اخي في العالم
مليارين من البشر او اكثر و استعمال
الاكتيف يعني مسيحي او النعت مسيحي
للارهاب هذه سائل لمسيحيين انا لا
اقبلها وان كنت لست مسيحيا فلن اقبلها
ابدا على الاقل انا دارس اديان وارى ان
هذا من الاساءات للاديان
وهذه مشكله الخطاب السياسي الفرنسي يعني
لو قالت هذا صحيفه ليست حكوميه لا باس
يعني على مسؤوليتها اما راس دوله 10% من
سكانه مسلمون في فرنسا يربط اسم الاسلام
بالارهاب هذه اساءه للمسلمين في فرنسا
واساءه لمليار ونصف مليار مسلم حول العالم
ثم نحن لو اردنا ان نرد بالمثل لما كان
الامر مناسبا في نهايه المطاف هو يقول لك
يمكن ان ترد بالمثل يعني هو هو لا مانع
لديه ان يصنفه اذا كان ادعى بانه قتل
هؤلاء في نيوزيلندا باسم المسيحيه فهذا
ارهاب ارهابي مسيحي هو يقول ممكن لا لا لا
ابدا هذا خطا وهو اعتقد هو نفسه لن يقولها
هو يقول وكرر يميني متطرب طيب يا اخي قل
هذا قل هذا يميني يميني مسلم او او يميني
يعني
متطرف مجرم يميني او متطرف او او متنطع او
غير ذلك من الاوصط لكن هذه هذا التجريم
بالاشتراك هذه ان كريمش باي اسوسيشن هي
عباره عن هتك لاعراض اكثر من مليار من
البشر واساءه الى مشاعرهم ويا اخي فرنسا
فرنسا قتلت مليون ونصف مليون في الجزائر
ورؤوسهم بعضهم رؤوسهم رجعوا من فرنسا كما
كما اعرف منذ اكثر من 100 عام وهم في متحف
فرنسي لا
احد يربط هذا بالديان الكاثوليكيه ولا حتى
بالشعب الفرنسي كله وانما سيرد عليك وقول
ان ذلك حث باسم السياسه وليس باسم
المسيح بالضبط نحن نريد نحن نريد ان ان
نتكلم بلغه السياسه حتى السياسي الذي الذي
يتحدث عن دوافع دينيه هو يظل سياسي لانه
الدين هنالك من من من ينقذ الارواح بدافع
ديني وهنالك من يقتل بدافع ديني حينما
اقتحم شارون بيروت كان معه باتر
برسن الزعيم الاصولي الامريكي و اريد ان
اقول انه مسيحي بينما كانت في في مع
الفلسطينيين في مخيماتهم تحت القصف ممرضه
بريطانيه مسيحيه ايضا يعني هذا هذه تنقل
الارهاب لدين له سيد ايف بوزو دي بورجو
يقول لك ضيفي الارهاب لا دين له وانت تقول
ان الارهاب ايضا لا دين له وتقول المسلمون
مرحب بهم في فرنسا ويمارسون حياتهم كفرن
السيين لكن حتى اللحظه لم تقل لي ما داعي
استخدام تعبير الارهاب
الاسلامويين كلنا متفقون على هذا التحليل
ولكن الامر الوحيد هو ام الاشخاص الذين
قاموا بالقتل هم الذين يقولون
انهم اسلاميين طيبهم سي سدي بورجو هم
يقولون ما يشاؤون هم بالاخر مجرمون ارهاب
لكن ان يتبنى رئيس الدوله الفرنسيه الصفه
التي يطلقونها هم على انفسهم فيطلقها على
الدين ككل الذي يتبعه اكثر من مليار هنا
المشكله التي لا يتقبلها اتباع هذا الدين
ومن ضمنهم الفرنسيون
المسلمون ما اقول بالنسبه الى نقاش مع
حضره البروفيسور الشنقيطي وهو شيق جدا نحن
لدينا هذه الطريقه
لاننا نتلقى الصدمه نحن في موقع تلقي
الصدمه لدينا مدرس قطع راسه طبعا هذا امر
فظيع صحيح اننا استخدمنا مصطلحات ولديه
الحق السيد شنقي
وانا اشكره وسوف انقل ذلك الى زملائي صحيح
يمكن ان نقول انهم اشخاص مجانين او مجرمين
ولكن بما انهم يفعلون ذلك باسم الاسلام
ربما نميل الى القول ان هذا هذه راديكاليه
اسلاو ولكن ربما يجب ان نقارب الامور
بطريقه مختلفه في فرنسا وانا فعلا يسعدني
هذا النقاش مع
حضره الدكتور الشنقيطي لانه فعلا يعطينا
هذا التصور الذي ليس لدينا اياه هذا
التصور من العالم العربي وانا اشكره على
ذلك وهذا النقاش كان فعلا يؤسس لامور افضل
الى المستقبل وهنا اشكرك سيدي بورجو الى
التفاتك هذه وهنا ربما ادعوك ل قراءه
التعليقات على صفحه ال مكافحه
الاسلاموفوبيا في فرنسا الى اي حد جرى جلد
بين هلالين هؤلاء بالقول ان الاسلاموفوبيا
لم تقتل احدا بينما الاسلامي اسم او الاسو
قتلت الى اي حد هذا الخطاب والذي يستغله
اليمين المتطرف والذي على اي حال قام كان
يحاول كان يحاول ان ان يقوم بجريمه في
بيون ضد احد المساجد الى اي حد يشجع هذا
الخطاب المتطرف على تغذيه التطرف اكثر
وعلى ايضا استعاره الغضب والحقد على
المسلمين
الفرنسيين اعتقد انني فهمت
ان من
قبل اليمين المتطرف هناك رغبه في تحوير
الموضوع وكلنا متفقون على ذلك ولكنني لا
اعتقد ان هذه المشكله الاساسيه الان اود
ان اشكر حضره البروفيسور الشنقيطي لانه
لفت نظرا الى هذا الموضوع وهذا يسعدني لان
صرت افهم الموضوع من نظره مختلفه ولا سما
انني اعتبر ضمن هذه القضيه نتحدث عن اشخاص
مهمشين في الاسلام وهم يقومون بما يقومون
به لاسبابه وهناك ملاحظه قويه اود ان
انقلها الى الكتور
شنقي وربما نحن ليس في مصلحتنا ان نعتمد
او
ان نتحدث بنفس الطريقه التي تحدث بها
هؤلاء المجرمون طبعا قال حضره البروفيسور
انه لا يجب ان نعتمد خطابهم وهو محق بذلك
اذا اذا دكتور شقيتي انت محق يقول لك
السيد دي بوركو كلمه اخيره ق قبل ان اختم
هذا الملف لدينا ملف اخر ا يقول لك شكرا
انك فتحت فتحت له افاق من زاويه مختلفه لم
يكن يراها تفضل انا اشكرك واشكره حقيقه
على على تواضعه وعلى تفهمه واتمنى انه
وجهه نظره التي تحاول ان تنصف المسلمين ان
تصل الى الرئيس ماكرون والى القاده
الفرنسي يسي الى مليار ونصف مليار بفعل
فرد مجرم ارتكب جريمه فظيعه هز مائر جميعا
فلا ينبغي ان نجعلها ان نعطي الفرصه لمثل
هؤلاء المجرمين لكي يسمم العلاقات بين
مليارات من البشر من خلال خطاب استعمال
لغه غير دقيقه وغير
حكيمه على تواضعه وتفهمه اذا يشكرك سيد دي
بورجو ضيفي دكتور الشنقيطي من الدوحه شكرا
جزيلا لك بدوري اشكرك من باريز ايف بوزو
دي بورجو العضو السابق في مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي شكرا جزيلا لوقتك و مساهمتك في
هذه الحلقه وشكرا جزيلا لك من الدوحه
دكتور محمد مختار الشنقيطي استاذ الاخلاق
السياسيه وتاريخ الاديان في جامعه حمد بن
خليفه في محطتنا التاليه يفتح محمود مراد
ملف استضافه تركيا مناورات جديده للنيو
ويقرا في دلالاتها وتاثيراتها المحتمله
على ازمه الشرق المتوسط